And you can sit there.
Then we can start!
Ada Hegerberg ...
I'm not sure whether you or I should say welcome, because we're sitting in Lyon -
- at a quite chilly football field.
But I'll say welcome anyways!
Okay. Merci!
Bienvenue!
How French have you become?
A Norwegian soul with a little touch of frenchness, I would say.
Four and a half years, it's been quite some time, now.
Do you speak French?
Yes, I do.
Well?
That was my first ambition when I came here, the French, I needed to learn that straight away.
You're the only woman in the world who has the Ballon d'Or.
... Which is the golden ball, which you won on December 3rd.
If you close your eyes and think of that night ...
What's your strongest memory?
I would say the mutual respect that was there throughout the evening.
It was such a powerful feeling to be present in -
- such a big group of big profiles, I would say.
And to feel that much at home.
And to feel that everyone respects each other for the work that is being done.
And to simply just celebrate -
- football at its highest level. And that -
That was very motivating, and a huge thing to see. For the future as well.
It was definitely about you -
- but you also became a symbol of something.
Yes. The night was about so much more than me.
I really felt that throughout the whole day, and also after.
It was a historical moment, and -
I feel that -
- everyone took part in it.
All girls, all women, both those who play football and those who don't.
To be the centre of a night like that was one of the biggest experiences of my life.
And it was bigger than me, because -
It was a big step in the right direction, for a lot of girls.
To set yourself a goal -
- to become the world's best player -
- when in the process did you do that?
The goal-oriented person in me appeared little after little when I was around 10-11-12.
It was a little later than my siblings.
They were big stars in the family.
Because you're definitely from a football family?
Yes. Mom and dad have played, my brother has played, Andrine plays in Paris Saint-Germain.
I didn't really have a choice. I would return from handball training and skiin and everything, but football was -
- the deal.
But it takes a lot of self discipline.
And ... I like to say that you need to dream big, but you also need to know the consequences of dreaming big.
Yes, because this didn't happen without pain?
And you're very well known for your self discipline, you're known for -
- your ability to train a lot.
Can you describe for us what your training has been like at its most demanding?
That happened quite often when we were around 13-14, that our dad pushed us quite hard, to know -
- where we were when we were at the bottom.
And that was such a hard mental training that from there, it only went up.
And that taught us how we could train.
And it gave us self confidence.
Because we knew that we were well trained.
And then we could just go for it.
But if you imagine that now, there's -
- lots of sports parents watching you -
- and, of course, a lot of young, potentially good, football players.
How hard should they be pushed, and how much should they want it themselves?
I've always gotten the question: «Is this what you want?».
And I've of course answered: «Yes. This is what I want».
And then you're there 100 percent.
But if I've said that «this is enough for me», then they've stepped down and let it be.
So they haven't dragged you out in the rain to ..?
No, no, no!
The wish to do it needs to lay with the individual, or me, or children, or youth.
The desire to be good needs to come from deep inside, and you need to -
- know that you need to do all the hard work.
But you need someone to help you push.
And I needed someone to push. And I wanted them on my team, and then it was -
- a huge support. But they also pushed me.
When you won the Ballon d'Or in December -
- that was -
- in a way a turning point that said something about -
- how we now see a different future for women's football.
But someone who represented the past that day was a French DJ -
- who managed to ask if you could twerk.
Which is a dance where you shake your bottom.
When you received the award.
Which was a strange thing to ask, and something he received a lot of criticism for.
Did he ever apologise to you?
He said he was sorry after the fuss started.
Because there was a lot of fuss, but I didn't realise that until later, because I didn't have time to  -
- to look at anything. And it exploded on social media and -
And I just thought it was a strange question. It would have been just as strange if a man had been asked the same question.
That's what I thought.
So he came over and apologised, and I said «the show must go on».
And I didn't put any more energy into it.
So that was a very unfortunate turn.
For his part. But people are on the alert.
People are on the alert with regards to these kinds of -
- comments. And that might show even more -
- that we've come a little further.
At the same time, I think that there are many other problems -
- that are worse than this case -
- that should be elevated.
So that night it just ended in a lot of laughs, at the whole thing.
Because you ...
He can play for free at my wedding!
That's the least he can do!
Do you now live like this football millionaire?
I treat myself to a duck breast now and then!
A duck breast?!
Yes!
My boyfriend and I cook duck breasts sometimes.
We have a good life, absolutely.
But ...
But I'm a regular person from Sunndal who has a normal life in Lyon, I would say.
Yes.
But there are a lot of football players with success abroad who have -
- shown that they have that success!
I don't have a Ferrari or a Porsche or anything like that.
You haven't bought yourself an expensive care because you ..?
No. But it's quite funny, because -
Right after I received the Golden Ball -
I left my car at the repair shop, because someone had put a dent in it.
And ...
I got a really nice Tuscon as a replacement car, a four wheel drive -
- and it was extremely nice, with heated seats and -
And I drove that -
- to the training facility the day after Ballon d'Or.
And I thought, «oh no, oh no, oh no».
«Don't let anyone see me in this car, the day after this!»
So I just hurried out of the car and into the football club.
And I got there and thought «phew». But everyone had seen it.
«Ah, so you just went completely overboard after that event!»
So they thought you had bought this huge car just the day after!
So now I've gotten my old car back.
My dad called me the other day and ...
«Have you gotten your old car back?». And I said «no, I haven't yet».
And he said: «I think you should get it back soon». And I said: «Dad, let me live like this for just a moment!»
But my old car is back.
We also have to talk about the Norwegian national team.
And there, you've sort of become the black sheep.
And I have to say that because you're actually sitting in a black sheep «fur»!
Nice word play!
But what happened there?
You left the team after -
The European Championship in 2017, which was a bad championship for Norway.
And you had a break.
And that break has turned into a more permanent ending.
The thing is that I've never felt that I've been able to influence in the way I would've liked to influence.
And I've heard a lot of things and there's been fuss about that I wanted to control the team and who plays -
- but we've never talked about it like that.
I quite frankly just felt that I've contributed with what I could contribute with, but it hasn't been enough.
And when I can't be a part of it myself anymore ...
... and contribute with what I know, and then be placed in a system that ...
... doesn't fit me, simply.
Then I can't continue.
In a way that they tried to curb you, or ..?
Yes, quite simply.
I've always had a lot of ambition.
And I've always had a lot of ambition on behalf of the team.
That we should be able to well together.
And that ...
That hasn't worked. And there was a lot of fuss. And that fuss ...
I really could do without.
Because I'm the one left with the consequences of quitting, not having a national team to play for.
I was very open to an open dialogue.
And I'm very honest, about everything ...
... internally.
I don't have a need to discuss anything in the media.
But there was a huge fuss. So ...
My goal was to keep focusing.
To move the focus to the next day, the next thing.
And that has been the goal ever since, and that has worked very well.
And ...
That's the way I'm going to keep doing it.
What needs to change for you to return?
Is there a long list of points?
There are clear points.
That's a thing that's between them and me.
And I don't have a need to share that with the rest.
And I think that ...
It's up to them, really.
I made my decision and am content with that.
I'm very confident that I made the right decision to move on in my career. And ...
But we Norwegians, we have the world's best football player, but at the same time, we don't ..!
Yes! And that's absurd! Because I've never felt as Norwegian as I do now!
And a Norwegian who wins a Ballon d'Or, to me, that's incredible!
And I'm so proud of that.
To come from a small place in Sunndal in Møre og Romsdal and stand on stage in front of the entire football world and receive a golden ball -
- is so extremely inspiring to me.
And it shows that no matter where you're from, if you think outside the box and work hard, then -
You can make it!
So even though I don't play for a national team, I'm -
- extremely sad that I can't play for my country.
But in this particular case, I had to make a decision to be able to move on.
And I ...
... am not losing my nationality because of that. I hope people don't forget that.
You still have your passport?
I bring my passport everywhere, it's safe in my living room!
What's your plan?
You have the Ballon d'Or, there isn't very much more ...
... to get?
Yes, there is!
Can you get better?
Yes.
A lot better, I think.
I'm very optimistic about that.
I hope.
But Ada, thank you so much for being part of this, and for letting us come to Lyon to meet you!
It's big for me as well. Thank you so much!